Khloe Kardashian slams rumor she's back
with her ex Tristan Thompson I think
keeping it a little private has really
helped us I've learned from experience
it keeps things close to your heart
speculation that Coco and the NBA star
are back together revved up after her
mom Kris Jenner Sister Kim and niece
Northwest were spotted supporting the
pro athlete at recent Los Angeles Lakers
games
Kim Kardashian Courtside but the reality
star recently slid into the comments of
a fan account to set the record straight
demanding that people stop pushing this
narrative it's tiring but I suppose you
guys will continue the narrative you
want regardless of what I say so what's
the point own whatever it is Coco adds
that the continued speculation is
exhausting and doubles down that some
things are just as simple as they seem a
family member supporting another family
member especially during during a
difficult time in life it's such a
beautiful thing and while she doesn't go
into detail about those difficulties we
do know Tristan's mom Andrea died
suddenly after reportedly suffering a
heart attack in January I don't have a
daughter but
um when I'm when I'm texting Chloe I
always put to my daughter
and in Chloe's comment she compares the
situation to how she supports her sister
Courtney's ex Scott Disick despite court
and Scott ending their relationship
years ago feeling left out and not being
told anything is super hurtful
especially when I don't have another
family to go to do you mind if I talk
about this with Courtney or would you
rather me stay out of it no stay in it
all I need is just to be acknowledged
right some things really are just as
they are exactly of course Chloe and
Tristan share two children together
five-year-old daughter true and a
nine-month-old son whose name they have
not yet shared publicly the on-again
off-again couple split in December 2021
after news broke that Tristan cheated on
Chloe and fathered a child with another
woman I was definitely very angry and I
think
feeling
Bamboozled the Revelation came just days
after Chloe claims Tristan encouraged
her to do an embryo transfer to have a
second child together via surrogate it's
just so close I wouldn't want anyone to
think I did this after the fact
why would I want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else but despite being broken
up Coco has publicly shown her support
for Tristan and remains focused on
raising their kids everyone has to
handle their co-parenting situation in
their own style and it's hard work for
all parties it's a beautiful thing to
get along with each other and for your
kids to see that now Chloe and her
famous fam are gearing up for season
three of Hulu's the Kardashians
streaming May 25th and Coco teases it's
full of drama I wish I could tell you
this is going to be a mild relaxing
Serene season
it's not I think that you have a real
insight into what the girls are doing
not only you know what you see in the
press or whatever but what's really
happening behind the scenes